[Music]
number one who will win call it now who
will win
who was the worst houseguest in terms of
roommate in terms of roommate I mean I
wasn't roommates with everyone I'm
sharing a house with people who was like
would not want to do that in the real
world I mean that's hard I don't know
none of them were bad I can I pass I
don't know
who is your friend for life from this
game the Big Brother itself the
producers the bait the game that not the
people but the game like I the
challenges I love doing the challenges
the love is still there people all right
what is the strangest thing you saw go
down in that house uh Brandi Glanville
tried to hump a squash she like
legitimately started to sit on the
squash and we made her stop like I don't
know if you guys got to see that
hopefully not I know there was a Peter
storyline but this was a prior Peter
Mike
why was Roger I think it was Roger live
feeders got to see this yes
all right and one word to describe your
Big Brother experience hole one word
okay this will be one word super
fantastic amazing incredible
once-in-a-lifetime it's all run together
I like that only you could spell have
spelled that word in the competition the
fragile istic yeah like that I thought
about that word
[Music]